Breaking into the spotlight as Sarah Connor
in James Cameron's classic film The Terminator,
Linda Hamilton became a pop culture icon.
Since reprising her role in 1991's Terminator
2, she's been less visible — but it turns
out, she never really stepped away from the
spotlight.
Where's she been all these years?
Let's take a look at what Linda Hamilton's
been up to since joining the battle to take
down Skynet.
Small screen
After The Terminator, Hamilton turned her
attention back to television, appearing in
the series Hill Street Blues, as well as TV
movies Club Med and Go Toward the Light.
In 1987, she stepped into the role of Catherine
Chandler on CBS's Beauty and the Beast.
The series earned multiple accolades during
its three-year run, including a Best Actor
Golden Globe for Hamilton's co-star Ron Perlman.
She hit her stride with big-screen success
in films like Mr. Destiny and Dante's Peak,
and then continued to jump back and forth
between film and television.
Starting in the late '90s, Hamilton guest-starred
in shows like Frasier, According to Jim, and
Weeds, as well as a three-episode arc on the
Syfy series Lost Girl.
In 2010, the quirky NBC action procedural
Chuck got some extra star power when Hamilton
joined the cast to play a former CIA agent
— and Chuck's sinister spy mother.
A shipwrecked marriage
For a brief period, Hamilton was married to
the man that helped her become Sarah Connor:
director James Cameron.
After Cameron split with his third wife, director
Kathryn Bigelow, he and Hamilton connected.
In 1993, she gave birth to their daughter,
Josephine, and from 1997 to 1999, the two
were officially husband and wife.
As Hamilton told The Daily Mail, Cameron wasn't
someone who could easily settle down.
She explained,
"The woman he can't get is always his dream
girl.
Work and women go hand in hand for Jimbo,
and I should know."
Cameron and Hamilton split when he fell in
love with actress-turned-environmental advocate
Suzy Amis, who he met on the set of Titanic,
resulting in a $50 million divorce settlement.
A mental health battle
In a 2005 interview with Larry King, Hamilton
spoke openly about her ongoing struggles with
bipolar disorder, saying that after multiple
mistreatments, she'd finally been able to
get the appropriate care to manage the illness.
According to Hamilton, the emotional swings
associated with the condition are one of the
main reasons her first two marriages came
to an end.
Hamilton explained,
"I really want to stress that there is no
magic pill for everyone...
I've got this huge busy brain.
I need to go and sweat for an hour and do
my weights for half an hour or an hour, not
every day.
It's no longer the compulsion, but I just
know that that helps me feel better."
"I like to speak out to let people know that
they're not alone at feeling control at times."
A meaningful role
In 2014, the Syfy network debuted Defiance,
a high-concept series released in tandem with
a video game of the same name.
Hamilton joined the cast for a six-episode
arc as a woman who suffered from mental illness
and lost access to medication after the arrival
of aliens, causing violent outbursts against
her family.
The series lasted only three seasons, but
it gave Hamilton an outlet to help educate
audiences about mental illness, an important
personal issue for her.
Discussing her character, she told TV Guide,
"Pilar is a fantastic character — manic,
mad and full of secrets.
This is why I love doing sci-fi.
You can go to so many more interesting places
than you can in some forensic cop drama."
Heard but not seen
While Hamilton has worked regularly, a lot
of the roles she's performed haven't been
in front of the camera — instead, her distinctive
voice has helped bring life to a variety of
animated characters.
She's become a mainstay in the DC animated
universe, where she's lent her voice to projects
such as The New Batman Adventures, Batman
Beyond, and a number of DC Showcase short
films.
Hamilton told Animation World Network,
"This form of creating a character is backwards
from what I'm used to, in that they start
with the script and your voice, and then create
around that.
It's a very different way of acting."
She'll be back
It's been more than 25 years since Hamilton
last appeared in Terminator 2, and in the
meantime, there have been a number of installments
in the Terminator franchise — 2003's Rise
of the Machines, 2008's short-lived TV series
Terminator: The Sarah Connor Chronicles, 2009's
Terminator Salvation, and 2015's Terminator
Genisys.
Now, according to Deadline, Cameron is getting
the band back together for a new trilogy.
"I've been waiting for you"
Reportedly, the next installment will ignore
the timeline explored in the sequels that
came after T2, and Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Hamilton will both reprise their roles.
Discussing Hamilton's return, Cameron said,
"As meaningful as she was to gender and action
stars everywhere back then, it's going to
make a huge statement to have that seasoned
warrior that she's become return.
There are 50-year-old, 60-year-old guys out
there killing bad guys, but there isn't an
example of that for women."
Linda Hamilton is definitely back — and
it sounds like she's better than ever.
"He said there's a storm coming in"
"I know."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!